I know you have had to see these videos
that we've all been seeing of these
little girls especially these little
black girls seeing you seeing your image
and how they react to just seeing you
what has that been like for you when you
see those videos wow it's been such a
beautiful moment for me to be able to
see the reactions of the babies it makes
me just emotionally overwhelmed honestly
and I cry as soon as I watch them
because I think of the little girl
that's still in me honestly and it heals
that girl inside of me and to watch them
feel like they have representation and
someone to look to to know that they
deserve to be in those places too it's
so important so yeah it just makes me
cry anytime I see any of those videos
part of your
[Music]
life
how does it feel now to officially be a
Disney princess yeah it feels absolutely
amazing to officially be a Disney
princess I mean I think that it's
something that we have all just had in
our dreams you know you have Daydreams
of pretending to be a Cinderella like
you know princess or someone like that
and you never think like it would
actually happen so I just am really
grateful to be in this position growing
up did you watch Brandy as Cinderella oh
yeah yeah oh yeah I loved brandy or
Cinderella she was so amazing uh such a
role model and inspiration and a really
big kind of studying point for me too as
I was taking on Ariel I just watched how
amazing she was in that role and how
comfortable she was in her skin and how
impactful that was to audiences and
little girls like me who watched it as
well as Anika Rose who's Tiana who's
just outstanding and I've had the chance
to meet her and we got to sing the song
Together almost there and like a Disney
sing-along with my sister
so she was always so kind but there's
these beautiful black women Pioneers
who've done this before and kind of been
there for me to be able to say okay I
can too The Little Mermaid is your first
project that you've done independently
so what was the biggest challenge you
faced stepping out working on this
without your family right next to you
ooh I would definitely say the biggest
challenge of this experience being
without my sister it was really just
missing her I mean I think that we have
built such a bond together and just such
a friendship and she is like my biggest
fan my biggest inspiration and I look up
to her so without her especially in the
beginning it felt like I didn't have my
right arm so you know but I'm so proud
of the growth that both of us have had
together and independently when you got
to see it for the first time were you I
mean what what was what was your oh my
goodness well when saw it for the first
time I watched it alone Rob Marshall was
like very particular and was like I want
you to see it alone in the theater by
yourself I'm like okay in like the first
20 minutes I was like the jaw dropped
and just like tears like non-stop
flowing because you know I consider
myself a musician and singer first I
never seen myself on this big screen
before so it's like all of these things
and emotions of wow that's me like oh
that's a little cringe that moment there
and then also like that's really me I'm
proud of myself so it was just a really
cool experience when you came in you you
had some ideas about representation and
how you wanted to show up yes to the
audience you wanted to wear your natural
hair and I love that was there anything
else that you said like I need to make
sure I stay true to myself in this way
yes well I think naturally I just really
tried my best to stay true to myself
um and every choice that I would make in
acting and especially in the songs you
know I was really grateful to Rob
Marshall that he gave me the freedom to
just be me and sing how Hallie would
sing and some of those inflections and
riffs I was allowed to do and that was
fun to be able to play because the
original music that we have is so
beautiful such a staple in all of our
childhoods and the fact that I got to
tweak and edit it a little bit was like
so much fun and a joy to have that
creative freedom
I don't know how that's just a
tremendous song and then I also sang the
song In A hierarchy than it is in the
original and I've jumped to octave
higher than in the original so I was
able to make it my own in that way and
then and under the sea I was actually
able to sing the one under the sea this
time because Ariel doesn't sing on under
the sea in the original so moments like
those are really fun when you get to
sing with your favorite songs
you are also going to play Young Nettie
in The Color Purple getting to be a part
of The Color Purple is such an amazing
moment for me I feel because it's such a
staple that film in our community
particular so I remember my grandparents
would always have it like playing in the
background and I was just really excited
to be a part of it not only because I'm
such a fan of the women that are in it
like it felt like fun family yeah you
had a family reunion you love seeing all
your aunties and cousins it literally
felt just like that and I was excited to
play Young Nettie because I felt I had
experience of Sisterhood that bond that
I have with my sister Chloe I felt like
I was able to pull from my experiences
with her and apply it to the beautiful
relationship between Celie and Nettie
and even though Nettie you know goes
away for almost half the film she's gone
but she's you feel her love and that
that thought of her um
foreign
[Music]